there is a big party happening at silver
state schools credit union the sponsors
of this segment today mercedes spoke
with president and ceo scott r kills for
more details check it out
scott arkle ceo and president of silver
state schools credit union so great to
have you back on las vegas now and we
are excited because
there's a big grand opening event
happening this weekend
that's right mercedes i'm glad to be
with you again too uh so silver state
schools credit union is celebrating our
much improved aliante branch location
today in north las vegas so it was
originally inside the smith store on
aliante parkway just south of the 215
beltway but this beautiful new at the
north end of the same
shopping center allows silver state
schools credit union to offer our
members a full service experience by uh
providing privacy we don't mean an
account when you're applying for or
closing the loan or when you're just
discussing your finances with one of our
member service representatives so we
invite everybody to stop by our new
branch location uh from 2 30 to 4 30 uh
for some refreshments and we'll also
have believe it or not casper soccer
rocker uh and the lights uh
football club llama which everybody
loves um uh if they're gonna be out
there if if you've got kids bring them
they absolutely love the wildlife so um
then we're gonna have an official ribbon
cutting and the best thing is that you
mercedes will also be there to help us
celebrate um thanks to mix 94.1 fm uh
and for directions to aliante branch you
can visit our website at
dot
silverstatecu.com
slash locations and uh and you'll be
able to find that location
yes i am absolutely thrilled to be a
part we're going to have so much fun 2
30 to 4 30 this afternoon and i've been
to that branch before i'm a member of
silver state schools credit union i love
being a member and and silver state
schools credit union has roots that are
really
deeply rooted in the education community
but membership is open to almost
everyone can you tell us a little more
about that
it is uh mercedes i'm glad you asked and
so um just a little history first in
1951 seven educators actually came
together to form silver state school
credit union so for over 71 years silver
state schools credit unions built a
strong foundation of becoming nevada's
premier financial institutions
we provide a gold standard member
experience and we give back to our local
communities in many ways such as our
annual scholarship program that we just
finished and also supporting financial
literacy and wellness initiatives
throughout the state
while school is in our name just like
you said anyone can become a member if
you don't meet our stated membership
qualifications through an educational
institution you can actually become a
member by making a one-time donation to
vegas pbs and we all love vegas pbs for
everything that they do and so with that
then you can begin to reap the benefits
of silver state school's credit union
membership and so to become a member
today i invite you to visit our website
that's also at silverstatecu.com
join
thank you silver state schools credit
union for sponsoring that segment give
them a call at 702-733-8820
or just visit
silverstatecu.com we'll be right